valuetainment giving
[Music]
what is this is the commercial on
okay it's my ipad actually hey hello
hello hello so today is what episode
176 with the great zoobee in town i
can't even say from where it's just
you're in town because who knows where
you live nowadays right you're traveling
all over the world yeah man i'm doing
the nomadic thing so
from the uk from the uk via
saudi arabia via nigeria but um i've
just been on the road now for the past
15 16 months and how do you like that
it makes sense for now it's not it's not
a for everything but the thing is even
if i had an house or an apartment i'd
virtually never be there so you would
virtually never be there i'd essentially
never be there no literally never be
there dudes on the road barely ever be
there yeah because i'm just doing events
and speaking and
performing and just just doing stuff all
over the place i love it i mean
if it's like a uh it's a good life for a
bachelor hard when you get married with
kids it's going to be challenging to say
hey kids so where do we live daddy
nowhere we're just everything in a van
down by the river find the nearest hotel
you always tell the story about when you
took the road trip for how long are we
30 bucks yeah yeah and you had kids and
you were married at the time right
mm-hmm
yeah i i was married and we had two kids
now you got four tico and dylan matter
of fact i think dylan was just born when
we went on the rv tour
and uh not was he something like that no
he was a year old or something but we
went all over the place with the rv
and had a great time but i slept
in the same bed pretty much every night
in that
in the rv yeah zubie just said that he
hasn't stayed in the same place for more
than what two weeks yeah two three weeks
yeah but
i mean
look i know that the world's been in a
weird place for the past two and a half
years stuff is stuff has been more in
most places more normal uh over the last
six months but i had no idea where stuff
was gonna go so for a whole host of
different reasons i mean i think long
term
i never plan to live in the uk
long term anyway i still don't i still
don't actually know where i'm gonna live
long term it might end up being multiple
places but i knew it wasn't gonna be the
uk and then when stuff just started
going going nuts over there last year
that was just kind of the straw that
broke the camel's back and i was just
like you know what for my own
for my own protection as well
i need to get out of this country and i
the the flexibility is
it's for a lot of reasons it's for
career reasons but also it's just like
i like knowing okay if stuff hits the
fan anywhere i can just be out i can
just be gone um i don't feel firmly
rooted somewhere because to me that's
like an anchor i don't even own a lot of
possessions like i don't own much um i
can have it it'll change when you get
married yeah yeah i'm sure it will and
i'm also hyper aware that that's on
that's in the cards for the future yeah
so i'm like okay right now i'm at this
very unique time in my life right now
where i can do this i've got the
financial freedom to do it i have the
career freedom to do it i have no
dependence right now
now's the time you know the world is
weird stuff is chopping and changing and
very unpredictable now's the time to do
this
let me add on to that because you you
hit the nail on the head you said
flexibility i talk about this all the
time especially if you're not married
enough kids i know you guys are married
and have kids so it's gonna be a lot
harder for you but i talk about having
low overhead and high flexibility key to
life these days things are moving so
fast especially with covet lockdowns you
don't know where you're moving you don't
know where you're going if you don't
have those dependents that you have to
actually
pay for and they rely upon you why
wouldn't you just kind of keep your head
on a swivel and keep it moving and yeah
pursue the best possible opportunity it
sounds like exactly and it's fun it's
fun too i mean it's cool just to be
i mean in two you know two weeks from
now i i can just be you know i just let
me just go to this place let me just go
that went to mexico city um a couple
months ago just on a whim i went to
antalya turkey
spent some time in dubai um how old are
you i'm 35. 35. yeah i'll actually be 36
in a year
but so the plans are eventually to get
married oh for sure unlike adam you you
do plan on one hundred percent no doubt
we're on the same picture i would like
to get married you know what's crazy i
was watching uh a video clip popped up
today of uh jordan peterson and he says
man is selfish until he has kids because
you don't know what life is like until
you have kids and you're thinking about
somebody else where you're willing to
die or live for that other human being
i sat there i'm thinking to myself i'm
like okay let's see if there's
credibility to this you know because a
lot of times
married people want to sell singles to
be married divorced people want to sell
married people to be divorced single
people want to sell married people on
being single you know people with kids
want to sell people on having kids
people with no kids want to sell people
on not having everybody is you know
everybody's you want to indoctrinate
others to your world that's right you're
not going to push them away
but if you really think about it like
you know the the argument of kids no
kids does having kids really change your
life in a dramatic way like if i right
now while we're doing a podcast you saw
my boys were here and they're upstairs
they're
taking a udemy class uh nine hours on
how to uh do a final cut pro okay that's
kind of what they're going through right
now but uh
2011 i had the last time i had no kids
was 2011.
and how
life was wired then versus today
a lot more freedom you can do a lot more
things uh two things that kind of locks
you down one is starting a new business
where you have to show up on a daily
basis and two is when you have kids
those two things and let me tell you it
is not
uh it's it's responsibility at the
highest level but today's argument is
also
do you really want to have kids in
today's climate do you really want to
have kids with what's going on today
yeah that's the that's the challenge if
you're somebody i feel
this morning i was listening to a uh uh
a cappella song that just totally messed
me up okay i listened to it 50 times all
morning i've been matter of fact i had
him listen to it i'm crying
he's crying
camera guy's crying this pops up this
morning and it's a song by imagine
dragons bad liar and it's a buck 26
minute 26
on youtube or instagram
and then i'm listening to this song and
then i go play it for dylan and i tell
dylan i said dylan you know there's
certain gifts god gives you that's not
yours it's the world this is what do you
mean i said if you got a great voice you
got to share it with the world you can't
just keep it to yourself you got to
share with the world
if you are somebody that's a leader
and somebody that's got strong values
and principles
we probably need more men like you to
raise kids because you would raise
better
kids in a society like this where not
only would the world benefit from it
your last name would benefit from it
your heritage would benefit from it
they're just that's the processing for
me with kids there are certain men that
i'll say dude don't have kids
just go ahead bro stay single the rest
your life but certain people you're like
look those values being duplicated
amongst one two three four other people
i wonder what the world would be with
you having more kids so anyways
sometimes the uh sometimes the wrong
people are having too many kids yeah
that's a whole nother issue that's a
whole nother issue exactly anyways let's
go into the topics it's good to have
zubi here uh we got a lot of topics to
cover today uh it's myself adam zubie
and uh tom also here on so tom say hello
to everybody i'm sorry losing it was
hamilton
that's uh believe that for a second
i have deep respect for the newest
minority owner of the denver broncos is
that lewis hamilton who is lewis
hamilton is in the ownership group
american football team i love it okay
let's go through some of these things
here first of all big news concerning
news u.s sanctions putin's reputed
girlfriend okay we're gonna have to talk
about that uh yes china would go to war
over taiwan
uh uh gallup surprise supreme court
approval ticks up after end of rove
deep mistrust has developed between
white house and zielinski it's an
interesting story california to fund
heroin injection
sites in la oakland and san francisco
pelosi says u.s will not abandon taiwan
as china plans military drills
americans are pulling up credit card
debt as they struggle to keep up with
the high cost of living
u.s household debt surpasses 16 trillion
on higher mortgages michael saylor
yeah we had on the podcast a couple
months ago steps down at microstrategy
ceo after they take a 917 million dollar
charge on bitcoin that's a yahoo finance
story
robin hood lays off 23 of their staff as
retail investors fade
from platform reality by to
cuddle tech staffer work working harder
is job number one
cnn's having a hard time they lost
substantial sum of money as ratings
plummet geico closes all california
offices lays off workers forbes set to
explore sale adam 630 million dollars
let's come up with that let's do
something jared kushner claims donald
trump tried intimidating him by saying
that tom brady was also interested in
ivanka which i love
salesmen i mean you gotta be equal
intimidation we'll get to the stream
inaccurate criticism appreciation on
millions of consumers and then tiger
woods turns down seven eight hundred
million dollars uh offer from lyft which
is uh can you imagine being in a
situation where you can turn that you
know what i'm good i i won't take that
7800 million dollars we'll get into that
as well but let's talk about
consumer.com americans are piling up
credit card debt as they struggle to
keep up with the high cost of living
so let's see what these numbers look
like
there we go yes i saw that increased by
uh two percent no that's not the one
american okay there it is u.s household
that surpassed 16 trillion dollars for
the first time ever during the second
quarter the new york federal reserve
said tuesday even as borrowing costs
surged the new york fed said credit card
balance increased by 46 billion dollars
last quarter over the past year credit
card debt has jumped by a hundred
billion dollars or uh 13 the biggest
percentage increase in more than 20
years credit cards typically charge high
interest rates when balances aren't
fully paid off making this an expensive
form of debt high inflation is also
making it more expensive to carry a debt
credit card balance because the federal
reserve is aggressively raising
borrowing costs tom what is really
happening here with that well the the
big headline on 16 trillion dollars of
total household debt what you have to do
is back off mortgages a little bit
here's a quick little case study for
people whenever you look at mortgage
debt you hear the word debt mortgage if
housing prices are higher and people put
20 down then the mortgage will be higher
but these could be mortgages are
perfectly good and people are paying
their payments and everything but the
mortgage debt number will be higher what
really jumped out to me was a credit
card debt that 13 increase is the
largest increase in credit card debt
over one year period in 22 years
that's huge the other side of it is is
right now delinquency only ticked up a
half a percent so delinquency on credit
cards was up but it's only a half a
percent it's up very little it reminds
me and we've mentioned this last couple
podcasts the movie the big short how
things were moving slowly and then they
suddenly popped
i think the big thing to look at right
now is delinquency because you also look
at
that
i was looking at a credit card stat site
i'm not going to say who because they
they kind of disagreed with two other
statistics but i think
that this one was right and they were
saying that right now if credit card
debt for the individual goes up another
17 to 20 percent you're going to start
to see delinquency because it's at the
max point that they've been looking on
the ability to make money that's a good
stat to know like i would want to know
how much you know how you have like a
ten thousand dollar credit card limit
but you're at seventy five hundred
dollars but maybe you can make the
payment just fine yeah but what i'm
trying to say is i wonder if there's a
way to figure out how much total credit
card debt
is out there and what the limit is like
let's just say
you know how it says 16 trillion dollars
or whatever the number is 16 trillion
dollars total total total all debt
combined 16 trillion is that credit card
debt every no no no no no that's all
debt okay that's how so of the of that
16 trillion to tom's point 10 of it is
mortgages so do do some basic math
what's 10 out of 16. well then you can
you're gonna have have
other stuff no yeah of course uh well
i'm saying i wanna know how much
like where are we at are we at seventy
percent are we at eighty percent or
we're saying credit card limit yeah so
if your limit is 10k if your
debt in it is 7 000 that's 70
right i wonder where we're at
because as that gets higher and higher
the other thing that happens is you know
you like the whole thing with
quantitative tightening credit card
companies are going to start also
lowering their limit for people
that's that's absolutely correct right
now if delinquency goes up one full
percentage point went up a half a point
but if it goes up one full percentage
point in a quarter the credit card
companies go to the lower
um
credit score people and they will
lower that number by 10
so if you had a 30 000 credit card it's
going to drop down you're getting a
statement that says your credit limit is
now 27 000. so they lower it 10
so as soon as you see delinquency go up
by one percent in one month credit card
companies are going to quickly flip the
knob over to prevent people from
borrowing past
the last 10
for the lower half of people holding
credit cards there's the answer to your
question so we are very very very very
close to that point
another 15 20 points of personal credit
card debt so if you have 8 000 debt in
your house
another 20 points is 9 600 bucks you're
not too far away and what if you've got
those energy prices you're doing 3 400 a
month you're only three to four months
from that creeping up simply because of
inflation cost of living and at that
point their delinquency rate would go up
credit card companies are going to turn
down so i think we're i think we're less
than a quarter away from starting to see
those stats on consumer spending because
it's all right here i'll put it in basic
terms
i have
with my brother in the car
we bonked the car
you know
on the side of the garage and we screwed
up the front fender
my mom is upset but my dad's not home
yet but three hours from now life's
gonna get real for my brother and i okay
and i think that's the kind of thing
that's going on five o'clock
yeah it's five o'clock and when dad
comes from eight o'clock and when dad
walks in at 7 30 mom's pissed the car is
messed up my brother and i are sitting
quietly at the kitchen table life gets
real you you think that's really where
we are right now so zubi you're
traveling all over the place what are
you hearing people saying about that and
the current financial situation
not a lot i'm not having a lot of
conversations about it to be honest um
what i was just thinking i mean these
numbers are pretty mind-blowing one
thing that's always perplexed me about
the usa as a non-american is the
is the way the obsession with credit
i find it really weird like i've never
even owned a credit card before
um and i i don't i don't even understand
the purpose of them
and to some people that even sounds
weird but just like the obsession dave
ramsey will appreciate what you're
saying yeah yeah but just like the
obsession with chris never owned a
credit card no i don't why would i i
don't see the point
i have cash um
like but everything in the u.s runs on
debt everything's debt and credit and
it's
i think maybe people here think it's
normal but it's not a global it's not a
global norm to the degree it is here
there's so many
people stack up credit cards there's
this obsession with with credit scores
and yeah like i don't even
you don't even hear about credit scores
in the uk can you pull up while he's
doing that and adam responds
credit card
i totally appreciate what you're saying
go ahead i'll tell you something else
else interesting here is um even with
like cars and stuff like the
like people talk about cars not in terms
of what they cost but in terms of what
the monthly payment is 100 and that's so
weird i've never been to any other
country where people even talk like that
you'll just say okay like how much does
the car cost if you can afford the car
you can afford it if you can't it's not
can you afford the monthly payment it's
can you afford
the car so i don't know what the stat
okay oh those are the stats oh there we
go okay well in muslim countries there's
a cultural thing about debt in general
oh it's not yeah and you're not allowed
to charge interest right correct in
islamic banking there's no sorry but
take a look at this so here's here's how
we car you buy it can't afford your
weight so usa average credit card debt
is 531
second is canada third is uk
then it's japan germany china france
italy brazil india i just pulled up a
stat here as well card ownership of the
2.8 billion
credit cards worldwide
1.1 billion is in u.s yep
and there's 330 people here say those
numbers okay of the of the all two point
there's 2.8 billion credit cards
worldwide
1.1 billion of those credit cards are in
the u.s which means
40 of the
that's like
to to to match it with population if the
world population is 8 billion
we would need to be a 3.2 billion so we
have
10 times the amount of credit cards that
we ought to have because yeah so that's
an interesting point about how america
is a credit economy yeah that's four
cards per person if you take 1.1 billion
cards and you take 330 340 million
people in the u.s and you take away the
kids and you take away the highly
elderly so those people in the middle
probably have about four cards each yeah
it's holy cow yeah it's really
interesting there's there are a lot of
things
that are unique to the usda that i think
a lot of americans don't realize and
perhaps think are
just international things but when you
come in as an outsider you notice them
and you're like huh that's weird why is
it
why is it like that another big one here
is uh pharmaceuticals good grief
pharmaceuticals like the amount of drugs
consumed in this country
um is astonishing i mean i think the usa
has what four percent of the world's
population four percent and consumes i
believe 90 of the opioids and something
like
70 i believe and you can check that
something like 70 percent of the overall
total pharmaceuticals why do you think
that is
big pharma there it
um
there's only two countries i believe in
the entire world where it's even legal
to advertise
uh prescription pharmaceuticals on tv
and in magazines and so on the usa and
new zealand so all these ads you see
like if you're all these ads every time
i'm looking at the screens these
pharmaceutical ads you know ask your
doctor about that's not even illegal
that's not even legal in most of the
world it's completely illegal across
europe it's illegal across asia it's
illegal in africa um and here it's cons
it's something like 60 to 70 percent of
the tv advertising revenue
and so that's a massive factor so
there's a huge incentive
for
drugs to be pushed whether this is even
even on children which is really
concerning right whether that's all
these the amount of kids that are
drugged up here is is it's crazy
it's crazy it's not it's not normal at
all um and i think it's probably a
relatively newish problem in the last
few decades i don't think it used to be
like that well i mean if you pull up
opioids death you'll see it is it is a
decade i don't even think it's two
decades i think it's a decade that just
spiked up
suddenly you you know what happens it
just validates that
as controversial as tom cruise was about
10 years ago in the matt lauer interview
he was right he's right he was talking
about ritalin he was right
he was right he's sitting there saying
well you got to take this and you go
what are you talking about says matt
matt you haven't done the research i
have matt you don't know what you're
talking about i do and everyone's like
what an arrogant so what if it's helping
her out and all this stuff is like no
you're not right
uh
by the way here's here's what it shows
it says in the eu the number of credit
cards carried per person is point eight
and not even one per person us is four
which is like a debit card for your bank
just a bank transfer card that's all you
have yeah yeah we just use debit cards
that's yes that's what i'm talking about
yeah yeah but then in that case there's
no there's no debt right i mean at worst
someone might have an overdraft but um
no it's just secure transport of money
yeah i don't know i genuinely don't
understand the point of credit cards i i
don't get it i've had people try to
explain it to me and i'm like i don't
get why i'd want that well why well i
will spend your own money you know you
can spend somebody else but i will tell
them but but i will tell you
amongst people
who who have money
uh uh uh
you know you'll see that guys who have
real real money they will not use a
debit card
and not because they're not using the
debit card because they don't have the
cash
they use the kind of a credit card that
you pay at the end of the month not the
kind of a credit card that you're like
hey you know i'm gonna you know
you pay off you know people have credit
cards that they pay at the end of the
month every month we have you know one
of our credit cards we pay i don't know
what the numbers every month four five
hundred thousand dollars per month that
we pay off because it's like a business
credit card but we have to pay it every
month it's not rolling right
and the reason for that is protection
because you don't want your debit card
number out there that's what you don't
want because that can be hacked into
your
cash where the money's at so that's the
only argument against
debit is to use credit that you pay at
the end of the month what you're saying
is which makes a lot of sense is the
credit card to just use and pile up the
debt i pay it off i paid off i paid off
and that's kind of the culture i mean i
got caught up in that in my early 20s i
was in that 49 000 and it was a mess it
took me a minute to pay that thing off i
had a choice between bk and paying it
off and eventually paid it off but it
was not an easy transition to go through
it so
um can i add to this yeah the um you
touched on it like i don't understand
the purpose of credit score i talked
about you know this all the time where i
don't really i mean i have a good credit
score not gonna lie it's 800 whatever
but it's like
if i'm more concerned with my net worth
yeah than my credit score that's what
people like you talked about the the
problem that we're having in america is
the credit score and credit cards has
been gamified i'm getting points i'm
getting miles i get to travel i get to
travel for free i uh who is the guy
catch me if you can the movie that
leonardo dicaprio played um
i'm escaping his name but the uh great
guy he's basically saying you need
abigail frank abigail exactly he was
saying you have to have a credit card
that's the only thing prevent fraud if
sometimes someone takes your debit card
and takes you know 10 grand off of it
that's going to be a lot more difficult
getting it back because that's your
money versus the credit card you call
the credit card you call it in so there
is this thing a thing with that
back to the credit card situation i
don't know if you're aware of this time
so i talk about the four c's of debt
everyone has to deal with this we've got
credit cards you've got car loans yep
you've got college right student debt
and the big one is cribs aka mortgages
if you obviously if you buy your house
right you know what you're doing but a
lot of people feel like they have to buy
they buy more house and they can afford
and they get into this mortgage debt
situation where it's we've all seen the
cribs on mtv payment base lifestyle
exactly can i go i'm just gonna do it
but here's the interesting thing about
credit cards credit cards during the
pandemic
was the only of those four that went
down 2.1 billion dollars for credit card
debt were erased exactly so people were
buying so people were buying cribs
people were buying more cars we all saw
that used car prices have skyrocketed
when has that ever happened
right and then people still keep going
to college but
uh credit card debt went down by 13 now
we had we had this big spike of up 13
because it went down because everyone's
sitting at home no one's traveling other
than zoo be traveling around the world
and everyone's just sitting home they're
they're getting stimulus checks they're
getting unemployment checks they're like
all right [ __ ] it i'll pay down this
credit card then so that's the reason
that it's escalated so if you look at
the credit card debt like i think
student loan debt is at 1.5 trillion car
loans are at like 1.3 trillion
and credit cards has never even reached
a trillion i think it's like hovering
between 800 and 900 billion it goes up
that's right that was the that's been
the peak it's been there a couple times
exactly but it hasn't hit a trillion so
it's not that big like the student debt
issue is way worse than the credit card
issue how much is student loan debt
total about 1.5 trillion
okay and then cars 1.3 trillion credit
card hovering between you know 750 850
900 as students are going back zooby
it's kind of interesting united states
sometime next year
it will be official
unless this economy causes people to put
their life on credit cards what's about
to happen is student loan debt is going
to be two times credit card debt
sometime next year it's already closed
if that number on the screen there's
right 1.75 yep i think it's even up from
the last time i checked the stat with
1.5 now it's at 1.7 trillion what this
has gone up
by the way remember how earlier i said i
wonder how much room is left in credit
so the 16.2 trillion is all mortgages
out on one's credit card right okay
the increase in borrowing which equals
302 billion over the last three months
reflected in higher prices for homes
cars in aggregate consumers still have
plenty of room to spend
with another 3.33 trillion in available
credit
that's a lot of money okay so 3.33
trillion in available credit since the
pandemic started about 42 million new
credit card accounts have been opened
and consumers now hold more than 750
million auto loan credit card mortgage
and home equity line of credit overall
consumer agents 30 to 59 have record
levels of debt
there you go it goes back to the point
you got to connect those two dots pat
i'm sorry
you have to connect the two dots what
hasn't gone up is wages and so the
delinquency rate regardless of how high
that credit ceiling is as soon as this
delinquency rate starts moving
that's when we're in trouble and that
ceiling's going to come down i'm sorry
go ahead yeah no sorry did you say there
were 750 million
car loans 750 million car mortgage
credit card so it's like
combined so if you run a credit report
and say you got a 28 thousand dollar car
loan you got a 476 thousand dollar
mortgage only you got a nine thousand
dollar credit card debt all of that
they're counting as accounts 750 million
accounts like that i think total debt
per person if you divvy it all up just
using those math i think the average
american
mortgages included owes about 50 grand
or 50 grand in debt so that's what it is
do do most people here have negative
self net worth oh yeah oh my gosh so the
running joke you'd say this in comedy is
like all right i just graduated college
and i just ran into a homeless guy on
the street he's asking me for money it's
like nah buddy i owe a hundred grand in
debt you're zero
okay so
who's worse off it's so confused like
this country really confuses me in so
many ways how it's like the richest
country in the world in certain aspects
but then
the majority of adults have a negative
net worth i mean that doesn't sound like
those sound like contradictory well
here's the deal you could be smart and
misinformed and stupid at the same time
you know you could be like making a ton
of money but also
broke [ __ ] yeah it's true that's america
for you baby welcome to america zooby
yeah
it's just really weird because you hear
these stats about i don't know what it
is like fifty percent of people couldn't
afford a four thousand dollar emergency
or literally something some i don't
wanna misquote the stat but no you're
right something like that
and then i mean when i just when i'm out
and about and you're just seeing all
these cards on the roads and you're
seeing the houses and stuff i'm like
how does that even make sense it's like
that doesn't well bro here's what i say
all the time there's a difference
between poor
and broke yeah so you said you grew up
in nigeria and then you saudi arabia
saudi arabia but your parents are from
nigeria okay originally yeah so but
there's certain places in maybe that
part of the world third-party world
countries that are you're poor right you
don't make any money you're relying on
whatever it is a day a dollar a day
we've seen these commercials unicef
whatever america most americans aren't
poor they're just broke they make 50
grand a year and they spend 55 grand a
year and they just make poor financial
decisions and that's why the average
credit card debt i think is about 6
grand the average student loan debt i
think is closer to like 35 grand so it's
not a shocker that student loan debt is
way higher than total credit card debt
because you could rack up 50 grand
student debt no problem
but in because there's not gonna be no
limit i think you can go to get your
master's take out another hundred grand
of debt student loan debt they'll ca i'm
sorry credit card debt they'll copy it
five ten grand whatever it is the
university thing is not this just
strikes me as completely unsustainable i
think we're i think in our lifetime
we're going to see such a huge
change and revolution in higher
education i think we're still running
off the fumes of previous generations
where people thought and a lot of people
still think oh you have to go to call
you have to get this degree to do this
you have to get
i think
like people my age and younger who are
starting companies and running companies
and so on i think
understand okay this is this is no
longer
the case i think many people in the
older generation
because they're still thinking okay when
i was
when i was a teenager or i was in my
early 20s
going to college was the thing it made
sense you had to do it for this and the
world has changed so much and i think
that
it's just the cr it's just the
credential now isn't it so i think that
just like you've had a revolution in so
many if you so many everything else has
been disrupted but education hasn't
everything else is i'm i'm a musician
right the music industry that was one of
the first right completely disrupted
photography disrupted movies
entertainment whole entertainment
industry completely disrupted so many
things are chopping and changing but
with education both school and
especially university level it's just
stagnant it's gotten way more expensive
why do you think and the value of it has
gone down why do you think
why do you think it's gotten more
expensive because there's an answer i'm
just curious why do you think the why do
you think it's gotten more expensive
when did it change
i don't know for the usa
so in the uk and in the uk it's changed
significantly because in the uk it used
to be taxpayer-funded so all the all the
mps and government officials in the in
the uk they went to university for free
right no tuition fees zero right not
nothing it costs nothing when i was
there
i want i think per year the tuition fees
were 3 000 pounds now i think it's about
10 000. so i left university 2007
so
so
it's gone from zero
to
uh say nine thousand over the course of
three years to thirty thousand um and
that's two thousand seven to now what's
the who's the sally may of uk i don't
i don't think there is one so so who
financed the school loan in uk
so if i'm going to if i'm going to a
school
do i go to the government get a loan in
a federal loan to to go to school i
believe it's a federal loan okay so it's
a federal loan so here's here's the
challenge on what happened from 1980 to
today i'll give you exact stats in
america okay from 1980 to today
inflation is up 217
just basic inflation so whatever was
worth
you know if you were buying something
for 10 bucks you're paying you know
whatever
20
dollar run ford right 200 what 207 217
inflation from 1980 until today
do you know what the college uh tuition
has gone up from 1980 till today
probably
1999 wow i'm sorry 1199 which is exactly
like 1200 percent so it's almost
inflation
six times inflation is up 217 college
tuition is up 1200
so now why here's why
if if you know how uh
if you start a new business okay and you
got this idea if you go to b of a wells
fargo what are the chances of being bfa
and wells fargo are saying no i'm not
going to finance it pretty high okay
banks like those types of banks are not
going to finance your
business idea if you have zero
credibility at like a half a million
dollar loan yeah okay whatever this is
not the 60s go somewhere else right so
you have to go get it from angel or you
have to get it from other people right
you're not going to get it from a bigger
bank
okay
if college education is so worth it
why don't banks finance it
let me say one more time college
education is so worth it because it's
not worth it so so call even banks don't
believe you're going to pay that back so
banks are like saying we're not going to
take that risk but the day the
government said
we will finance college tuition for
every dollar that bank that the
government finances colleges can
increase at 60 cents
so i don't know if that makes sense or
not so every year so you know like you
and i there's a certain regulation you
have when you're competing it's a
monopoly you know you can't compete all
this other stuff so everybody's
targeting companies well they're a
monopoly they're this they're that okay
the ultimate monopoly and everyone's
back you know
corporations don't pay taxes first of
all let me give you one crazy stat crazy
stat on this
there's 13 universities in america that
have
10 billion dollars or more in their bank
account cash they call it endowments
okay harvard number one right harvard's
number one at 53 billion
but you got 10 or 53 billion okay in
savings now let's see who the real
greedy people are watch the statistic
name me a the
you know fast food place we've gone to
the biggest fast food place in the world
what's the name of it mcdonald's how
much do you think they got in cash
so remember the 13th university has 10
billion in endowment it's just a college
okay how much do you think mcdonald's
has in cash
tens of billions 2.3 billion that's it
right
that's it they got 50 000 freaking
locations worldwide employing hundreds
of thousands of people worldwide they're
only sitting on 2.3 billion dollars
they're the greedy people how much you
think starbucks has in cash four hundred
thousand employees
one how much do you think star wars do
you see where you're going now now
you're thinking about it right because
these starbucks only has three billion
dollars in cash check this out facebook
trillion dollar company only has 54
billion dollars in cash the same as
harvard how the hell does facebook have
the same amount of cash as harvard tesla
massive company only 18 billion okay
disney massive company only 16 billion
in cash how
how so so so and then they have the
audacity to say corporations don't pay
taxes but no one has the audacity to
call out colleges while they pay this
much taxes march madness zero in taxes
football zero in taxes they get away
with all of that and they get to charge
parents more money every year and
pressure parents to finance their house
and take money out you're absolutely
right i think i think the phase we are
today people are starting to realize and
question everything people like yourself
people like us were like dude
i don't know what the hell is going on
but i'm questioning and i want to learn
more how the hell does starbucks only
have 3 billion how the hell does
mcdonald's have 2.3 billion in the bank
and we've got 13 universities that have
10 billion or more in the bank see this
the kind of stuff where when you
question it and you kind of open up the
you're like holy [ __ ] they got no
competition and the government's got
their backs and if education is so worth
it why aren't banks financing it maybe
it's no longer worth it yeah and the
worst thing that happened to colleges
and universities you know what's the
worst thing that happened government
getting involved you know what's the
worst thing not the best thing that's
the best thing that happened to them you
know what's the worst thing that
happened to colleges and universities
the internet covet oh okay
best thing happened to us worst thing
that happened in college and
universities you know why
because covet forced people universities
to get cornered covet happens then
harvard students and parents are like
look now that everybody's doing from
zoom and they're no longer on camera
lower tuition yeah you're going to be a
low tuition on harvard no no the stamp
of approval of harvard did you still
have to pay full tuition and then they
said well i thought the experience of
college was
you got a insurance policy because if
something doesn't work out you can
always say i got a degree from this
school i thought it was about the
education i thought it was about the
pride and i thought it was about the
network and the experience of being
there oh
so now i can get a degree online
i don't need to pay this anymore so i
can be a nomad person traveling the
world and still get my four-year degree
hey mom hey dad why don't you finance me
track my grades just allow me to travel
the world while i'm getting my four-year
degree i would much rather do it that
way the worst thing that happened to
colleges was covet and they're going to
pay a price for it long term yeah so
covet plus the internet covered plus the
internet yeah absolutely
can i give you a little pushback maybe
go forward all right because it's a
little bit more of an by the way we're
on the same page here the word
entrepreneurship we didn't hear growing
up like our age if you're in your late
30s early 40s when did you hear about
entrepreneurship tom you just turned 60
happy birthday by the way when did you
hear about the term entrepreneurship it
was
probably five years out of college okay
i knew what it was and i i i knew the
concept i knew there but the economy of
all the startups and everything like
that you know i was in la so there was
proximity to it but it wasn't as
um it wasn't front of mind and it wasn't
like
seen as a valid option
now
the whole notion of side hustle is micro
entrepreneurship and it's very what are
you doing for a side hustle you know
exactly well anyway where i was going
with this argument is that because
it's conflicting because you're going to
want to send your girls to a good
college i assume
oh they're not going to study art
history they're not going to study
anything but you're sending them to
college i think it's a good idea for
doctors and nuclear physicists to get an
education yeah i think stem and law out
yes totally agree yeah i agree the
problem is and i went to college but i
always tell people i don't even know why
the hell i went to i just went partying
and hanging out with chicks the whole
time and maybe i went to class
but
if you look at the stats
and this is comes down to individual
responsibility if you look at the stats
the average college graduate will earn
double what a high school graduate will
earn in their lifetime so let's back out
the numbers if you go to college average
college student will make two million
dollars over their lifetime
okay the average high school student
high school graduate will make one
million dollars okay so if you're going
to take out 50 grand in debt let's just
say that's a pretty fair trade-off to
take out 50 grand to make an extra
million dollars college isn't the
necessary factor though i i was about to
say that but go ahead make your point
and then
we'll have something i'm i'm with you on
this however
the the challenge is where are you going
to college like you said you're not
going to do an art history major that's
really what it comes down to is like
your four-year degree you can take it a
state college state school pay the
normal
you know state tuition
and if you can get into harvard or yale
or stanford you're going i don't care
what you say you go to harvard you take
the opportunity you'll deal with the
ramifications of the debt at a later
date but it's when you go to like
oberlin college in wherever some liberal
arts and you pay out-of-state tuition
where you could have just gone to
you know fiu here in south florida or
fau whatever but you know i'm gonna go
to
whatever random private school in
whatever city because you want the
college experience that's where you end
up spending instead of 50 grand 250
grand and then depending on your major
because certain majors have different
roi yeah that's the difference yeah
let's be real a lot of degrees are trash
i agree
most
there's a small handful of the
traditional ones which we know you've
said stem
law
you know you want to be an
engineer a doctor
a lawyer like there's certain ones
very obvious anything that ends in
studies nonsense
right anything with studies in the title
nonsense
and then there's other stuff that's more
kind of in the middle you know
geography
history english
might be useful for some very specific
niches but you probably
going into a huge amount of debt to get
that degree in this day but the problem
is you're probably you have to make this
life-altering decision when you're 17 18
years old how the hell do you know what
you're going to do the rest of your life
i put this up so you're like all right
do i go to college do i not go to
college i put on parents i mean this is
an interesting one because my
perspective has changed on this a lot
not because of because the world the
world has changed and the reality has
changed and the opportunity cost and
real cost has completely changed so
for example um
when my
oldest brother when when my oldest
brother went to university in the uk
you didn't have to pay anything out out
of pocket right taxpayer funded you know
tuition fees covered right so this is in
the in the 90s it's like well if you're
in the uk going to university was like a
no-brainer it doesn't it barely costs
you anything
um
like there's it's just upside right like
why would you not go assuming you're
mentally capable of going why wouldn't
you go yeah you you may as well go and
the value of a degree was still high
because there wasn't in the internet and
all these different options and
opportunities it's like yeah you know
you get a degree get a job you're good
to go and then i
you know years later you know a decade
later i go to university and it's like
okay the cost has gone up now you're
starting to we're starting to move into
this world i was in university 2004 to
2007. we're starting to move into this
internet era but it's not like it is now
kind of in the middle okay the costs are
there's some cost but it's it's still
very affordable three thousand pounds
per year very for you know very
affordable
and then
now it's like okay another 10 years
passes by the cost has tripled
the value has dropped you've introduced
even all these new majors and courses
which are complete nonsense and it's
like the equation changes so by the time
i have
kids in there 17 18 if assuming it keeps
going on this trajectory
i have no interest in them going to
university right unless it's like for
something very very specific because the
world has just changed so much right the
the
so this is this is the thing i think so
many parents and you know i understand
it i'm not trying to
put them down or any way but i think
they're still viewing it as in okay in
the 80s or in the 90s
this is how it was and they're still
viewing it the same way they're not even
realizing that oh okay like they're not
getting the same you're not getting the
same value it's wild that you're getting
all these people coming out of
university and then you go and work and
you go and work in starbucks or you go
and work in a shoe shop or do something
that you you could have just done
without a degree and you have to
consider the opportunity cost what else
could you have done
in that three or four year
period or five year period right it's
not just that you're going into debt
it's like okay you you're losing out on
earnings you're losing out on experience
in there's some degrees that make you
dumber right if you go and you study uh
women's studies and with a minor in
queer theory like you're coming out
dumber than
then you went in or maybe just more woke
dumber
like no really like like you're coming
out worse you're actually coming out
worse you're coming out with less common
sense less grasp on reality more of an
in less of an ability to communicate
with normal people you've just been
depending how far you go down that
rabbit hole that well if you major in
that for four years you're going to come
out with some loopy ideas and it's a
ponzi scheme because the only way you
can even make money from those degrees
is going back into academia and
brainwashing another generation but but
i got to tell you this okay so
just just think about if you had all the
resources in the world okay
and say you have 10 billion in the bank
and you're at a point you've traveled
the world
you have kids you're 59 years old zooby
king zooby you're 59 years old you got
10 billion in a bangle beautiful wife
your kids have done your kids are doing
great they love you life is good married
happy everything you're politically
making an impact you've done great for
yourself
and then you're seeing a big league in
education
and if you chose to start a university
how would you start that university and
what would you teach what would be your
format because there is a leak in it and
there is experience in there's a big
difference between us doing the podcast
this way versus us doing a podcast on a
zoom
you're sitting right here in flesh i'm
sitting right here in flesh we're having
this conversation it's a little bit more
intimate versus hey zubi so how are
things
so that there is that intimate
experience
so if you have 10 billion and all of a
sudden you get the itch and you say you
know what i just think you know we do
need a university i do think we need to
do something there there's a way of
doing it better how would you do it
better i have some ideas i'm curious how
you guys would do it better that's a
great question i mean the first thing i
would do is have this conversation with
smart people in different fields
successful people in the world of
science and law talk to doctors talk to
people like yourself entrepreneurs and
see okay what
we've been running with this system for
for centuries right the world has
changed massively in each person's field
and sector let's have this conversation
and see okay like what would
what would what would you want to teach
what do you think would be valuable ask
that of different people and then over
time i would i wouldn't put it all on
myself and think you know oh no i'll see
your horse i i have the knowledge of all
these you know i just know but even for
you just for you like ideally for you
like okay so for example um
you know uh
you know like you you you start a
restaurant okay and if we're starting a
restaurant together the four of us first
thing let's just say okay what do we
want to do do we want to make it a niche
what do you mean is it sushi if it's
sushi we're doing sushi if it's you know
american we're doing burgers okay we're
doing that if we're doing italian we're
doing italian if we're doing are we
doing a mixture are we doing like a uh
fusion is that what we're going to be
doing okay let's just say we're doing a
fusion what's the fusion between let's
say we're doing peruvian and chinese
food combined like chino chiclano by
jose andres okay we're doing a fusion of
mexican food and you know uh whatever
food perfect that's where you took me in
vegas that's what you're coming up with
is in dc vegas is poblano pomona's
mexican and chinese it's okay so then we
make a menu
and we say what do you like on the menu
you say i like these seven things to eat
what do you like i like these nine
things tom what do you like i like these
six things tyler what do you like i like
these eight things we added then we look
at the list and we say guys
which one of these can we eliminate
and one by one by when we eliminate and
we keep the top
40 of the items on the menu that we all
love okay i think the first step is take
all the topics yes that are teaching and
look at it and say uh which one of these
you're going to use in your life yes
okay
and i want to say okay let's take the
top 20 of things that we are going to
use okay
and then let's add new things that
nobody else is teaching to it business
entrepreneurship negotiation sales money
let's add this to it right in fitness
health and fitness let's add this to a
diet like that kind of stuff let's add
this to it and let's go with it and by
the way if you want to study philosophy
go to university of whatever if you want
to study this go over there our school
is to teach you stuff that you're going
to apply in your life and then here's
what makes us unique adam what's that
two things number one fifty percent of
our um
professors are former operators what do
you mean
it's a form of a contribution to society
hey adam you're 63 you've made a lot of
money
you don't need to make another 50
million bucks
are you willing to contribute six hours
of your week to society yeah what do i
need to do a class a day for one hour
i can do a class every other day no
problem let's start off with that adam
is now a professor teaching basics of
money because he became financially free
but he's not talking as a guy that
desperately needs the salary he's
talking from a guy that's worth 10
million dollars here's how i did it
these are the mistakes that i made right
okay zooby your topic is going to be
this how do you want to can you are you
willing to contribute to such that guys
i can only do two hours a week no
problem it's fine here's what we're
going to do then my format will be the
following format
in topics that there needs to be a lot
of debate the class would have two
professors not one professor
if we do religious studies i'm going to
have a christian and i'm going to have a
whatever pick another
denomination or not denomination
religion muslim put catholicism
mormonism judaism pick them okay
and that's what it is so you debate and
i debate and i'm the student i'm
enamored the entire time because i'm
like what a freaking format you're
sitting there teaching history have a
couple people debate
every class would have two professors
not one and the format would be debate
because i think what we're saying here
with universities i think if a
university like that existed i would
love for my kids to go there like the
idea has got to be dude i am so
happy my kids are in your hands thank
you i'm so happy my kids are in your
hands i was at a wedding
last november
and at the wedding the father the guy
that was getting married shows up to me
and he gives me a hug and he starts
crying he says listen man i'm so glad
you got a hold of my son at 18 years old
because it because the teaching the
environment
changed so
i have kids i know eventually these kids
got to go learn from somebody else for
me to be able to say my son is spending
a quarter with tom i'm like it's coming
from a place of dude that kid is gonna
come better so the idea of education for
parents needs to be i can't wait to meet
the final product of my daughter or my
son but that's not the feeling today
okay however if you are woke left if you
are liberal and you are sending your
kids to uc berkeley guess what you are
going to get exactly what you were
hoping to get when the kids come come
out of college yeah if that makes any
sense yeah so but and that should be and
that should be their their choice all
right let's put it up to the right put
up to the free market
have these different and we'll see who
turns out better
i love the debate philosophy another
problem is that
we touched on this a lot of these
teachers
are don't have understand money don't
understand unless they're an economics
professor don't understand how money
works and the economy will understand
less about money than anybody else
sometimes so like here you have these
teachers and respected teachers i mean
i'm not gonna [ __ ] on teachers but
overall i think they you know we they're
that's a necessary component of society
but
you go to school to make money
or to learn how to make money and then
you're learning from people that don't
know how to make money so it's sort of a
backwards philosophy i think we'd be
doing a disservice if we don't talk
about the advantages of a lot of people
going to technical schools
in america it's you're frowned upon if
you become a plumber right or if you
become an hvac technician or if you
become any sort of electrician working
with your hands it's like these guys
make six figures you know you know
what's going on here and and this is the
this is the case with many things in our
society is there's this concept of
perceived legitimacy
and i think this is what these
universities are still running on some
of them rightfully so
right but many times it's it's all smoke
and mirrors and fumes it's branding
right so
why should
you know why why does somebody say if
someone says oh you know i work in this
legal office and i make 80 grand
people look at that one way and a
plumber who's making 120 grand you look
at a different way or an electrician or
a mechanic or something right it's it's
this concept of like perceived
legitimacy or clout or sort of prestige
but a lot of it is just branding and
marketing that's kind of been put in
people's heads for decades that causes
them to kind of turn their turn turn
their nose up a certain things or frown
on certain things and look at other
things isn't like oh wow this is amazing
um and i think that as you as we've all
alluded to people are waking up to them
and i think this is going to be a
generational shift i think all far more
younger people people
say under 40 certainly under 30
are looking at the numbers and are
looking at
by now we've had a decade of people
coming out of college in multiple
countries who can't get
can't get a decent job right and people
are looking at that and waking up to it
and experiencing it themselves and are
like hmm okay i did this thing even if
you even if someone's there with 100
grand debt and you're 27 years old and
you're now thinking honestly if i'm
honest with myself that wasn't worth it
it wasn't worth me going into all that
debt to get my degree in
history or fine art um they'll make a
different choice when they have children
right they're gonna look at that
situation and be like okay
my parents did this because you know
they thought they thought it was the
best for me maybe they encouraged and
pushed me to go to college because
that's what they did and it worked out
well for them but look the world has
changed the game has changed there's new
technology there's new options we don't
need to kind of keep going down the same
thing because ultimately when you think
about what is the what's really the
purpose of education and i think people
get this twisted right people confuse
i've said before that um
education is
cheaper free
but college is expensive
people conflate college and education
they're not the same thing you can be
extremely you can be highly highly
educated very very knowledgeable
and not have a university degree you can
have a university degree and be very
ignorant and naive and
not very intelligent i don't know how
many people go to college because they
want to get smarter no it's a return on
your investment to have a career in jobs
or you can make money that's it yeah
yeah but it's not even
it's not even really that practically
right for so many companies again the
legacy companies
the the college degree is just a filter
it's a it's a filter and i think a lot
of those big companies such as the big
tech companies are no longer
exactly demanding that you have a
college agreement this is what i'm
talking about so they're waking up and
going okay actually
what do we we want to know that you can
do the job and do the job well
maybe 20 years ago a degree was a very
good sign of that
now for whatever reason
it's not we want to know have you got
the skills and so i i think that
i think there's a disruption that's
happening i think we're in the early
phases of it we've seen it in all of
these other sectors just over the last
few decades and i think that the same is
going to happen with education and i
think once that perceived legitimacy
switches from just being oh you know you
you have to go to this college or that
college and it just becomes oh okay
there's these other options and there's
these other ways and we respect that and
that's and that's valid and that's
legitimate and we don't frown upon that
then i think the whole game is going to
i think it's already happening and i
think and it'll also cause the colleges
to have to respond and react to that
because if they want to keep attracting
and getting students they're going to
need to step up their game they're going
to realize okay we can't keep charging
people 20 grand a year to learn some
nonsense that they're not going to get
any real value from because they're
starting to get hip to the game yeah
it's happening it's below the surface
pat and i are both very passionate about
education i mean at the core my alter
ego the biz doc is a teacher um that's
me and i look around it i went to state
school
cal state northridge because that's what
i could afford um no scholarships no
athletic ability that's what i could
afford
and i did pretty well because i was a
smart kid i learned some things i
studied business administration
marketing so the finance was valuable
certain things were valuable they made
me take some general ed courses
geology and stuff because i need science
credit i don't think that was valuable i
think it was profitable for the school
sure i don't know that that's
prerequisites you're required to take
these classes before you can start doing
your major [ __ ] what pat and i did
we went to a uh uh conference and um uh
uh gsb puts on an education conference
and we went and saw there are lights
shining out there and i might want to
hold any up but
gsb you gotta you gotta clarify gsp is
not george st peter this is a gsv
they was getting protesting outside
correct yeah it was asu gsv uh summit on
education but really it was a showcase
of some really clever companies one was
out there to you and because we were
both very impressed with this guy chip
pasek
who
came out there and said hey i'm going to
make technical education available for
the masses without the debt overhang so
you can go
learn how to code and to be a
computer science engineer and then go
get yourself a job in an industry that
had a shortage and so they'd love you to
get skills in two and a half years and
be available they wouldn't
rather than waiting for you to go
through mit or caltech for four years
and so there i think are lights shining
there and also i think people need to
pay attention to things online education
united states a lot of colleges of the
university are just waking up to it yes
if you look at ads on tv like espn and
stuff you'll see s uh southern new
hampshire university grand canyon
university you know the ones i'm talking
about
you don't see cornell average university
well university of phoenix had another
problem and it's a shadow of what it was
and it's i don't think it's really doing
it right but the ones i'm just talking
about they are effectively educating
people distant from their homes while
cornell is like we would never do that
why because it's not the economic model
that cornell wants to keep once again
but are those online universities
actually worth it because i don't know
how many people go to those universities
because they
want a degree in something or
a major education it's just like i got
to get a [ __ ] degree let me just do
it online all right cool bang it out
boom southern new hampshire well that's
part of the thing that is slowly moving
is you're slowly seeing things move or
corporate america is not using it you
were so correct he called it the
filtering mechanism that's exactly what
it is it's a filtering mechanism okay
you have a degree and from where did you
get the degree yeah
from southern
university now you i'm going to another
level right you i don't care where
someone got an education as long as they
can show me what they did yeah you know
we hired a business analyst i didn't
care where he got his education as long
as he could show me what he did he was a
smart guy we trained him and he brought
raw materials and worked out great for
us
that
that is
and by the way why do we do that at our
company because where we came from we we
weren't ivy league bigots we didn't look
at it that way and pat say wow is it
from this school to that school we
looked at him and say is he smart clever
smart clever two different things right
is he dedicated is he focused is he
teachable is he personable we looked at
all these things and said okay he's
bringing raw materials and he already
knows how to do this and this we're
going to show him the rest yep and guess
what the guy had a really good run with
us another thing that's so major is
because when i think of education in
general um both school and university
level because a lot of this stuff can
filter down to schools as well is i
think okay what are the things that no
matter
if you're an adult you're gonna have to
deal with these things right no matter
what you choose to do how you live your
life there's certain things that we all
have to deal with that's why i brought
up health health and nutrition right we
all we all have a body we all eat food
multiple times per day and we've got one
body that we need to take care of right
so
to me it's ludicrous that someone can go
through a
multi-decade education process and you
don't learn at least the basics of
taking care of your body that's insane
right
money
we all deal with money whatever job you
do however you live your life whether
you stay single you get married have
children
you're gonna have to deal with money
you're gonna have to deal with money and
with finances
gaping hole like there's that's not even
a subject
how's that how's that not a school
subject right this is where i start
thinking everything is a psy because i'm
like that
benefit exit that's where i think it
can't be accidental right they want
people to be stupid about these things
so you're gonna have to deal with those
things of course communication
communication right and not what to
think but how to think right like being
able not everyone has the skills to have
this type of conversation they haven't
learned how to communicate how to listen
not just how to talk and how to read and
how to write and how to understand but
how how to just sit down and listen to
another person
and
you know control your emotions and you
know know when to
all all of these things are really
important skills and as as we all know
as as entrepreneurs and people who do
what we do
so much of it isn't just the
hard math and hard science and heart
it's like cool like those are important
in certain ways but it's
can you relate to people do people can
you communicate can you get an idea
across can you influence people can you
persuade people all of that stuff and i
think we have that i think we have that
at universities i just don't know if you
know
some do it better than others i think
that is taking place and a part of that
like look let's not get it twisted even
if i go to the best school based on
everything that i just talked about or
you just talked about that they're gonna
offer and you come out you still could
fail in life and you still could still
be a schmuck because
you're not gonna be able to apply this
stuff it still goes back to the
individual when they come out right like
when you say the average person that
finishes college it makes two million
dollars more than the other person that
doesn't okay is that the college or is
that because the kids got the discipline
to finish things he starts we don't know
so what are we going to give the
credibility to we don't know the data
there right then the whole debate with
are men better drivers than women you
know a guy was showing me one of the
tate's videos about the guys questioning
him saying hey are women better drivers
than men and i'm sitting there saying
this guy's actually making the argument
and he's serious about it says well yeah
women are better drivers than men
according to data data sometimes lies
what do you mean by that
first of all okay so
let's let's talk about a couple
different things when it comes down to
why insurance is cheaper for women than
it is for men number one who in their
lifetime drives more miles men or women
who drives more miles is it even a
question well if you're going to include
truckers
not this man but i'm saying like most
men nobody's ubered more than me around
here most men drive more miles than
women do okay second statistics if we
were to take the average
speed men go versus the average speed
women go
how many more miles per hour do you
think men go than women probably
probably i was going to say 10 miles
right okay if you're going 10 miles
faster than women dude the chance of you
get into an accident it's probably if
it's 50 miles 10 20 higher of you
killing yourself in car accidents okay i
totally get that but does it mean women
are better drivers than men no but
sometimes data is so misleading like two
million dollars more you know
who calculated it how do they calculate
it what are the factors what are the
things that we're not given are we
giving way too much credit to the actual
college education and not enough to the
individual are we giving credit to the
upbringing of the parent there's so many
different factors but it's easy to
always just give the credit to
it's because the colleges there's way
more factors to it than just colleges
again i want to change topics sure you
have some stuff to say about saudi
arabia let me just first give credit to
a couple uh
uh super chatters we have the mind of
veena gave 50 bucks it says part of the
u.s brand part of the brand us identif
identity is bigger is better whether
good or bad this is true for military
complex debt obesity drugs excess good
bad skyscrapers everything is bigger
than u.s identity this is abundance but
also egregious excess brand look at
texas everything's bigger that's right
hello come on now medley butler iii says
zubi the purpose of credit card debts
were never meant to be for the consumer
through fractional reserve lending banks
multiplied the full credit card limit by
10 and loan it out to consumer uh to
someone else as soon as you swipe it
into existence
thank you smedley and uh outside of that
i want to talk to you about saudi arabia
and go sure okay okay
so
we went viral last time we talked about
saturday yeah that one crazy this
phenomenon with tiger woods turned down
live golf
700 million to an 800 million dollar
offer that's the biggest offer they made
to anybody this was in an attempt to
lure the 15-time major winner away from
the pga tour according to liv golf ceo
greg norman the number has been out
there yes norman said tiger is a needle
mover so of course you got to look at
the best of the best they originally
approached tiger before i became ceo so
yes
that number is somewhere in that
neighborhood the saudi arabia golf
league has grown notorious for offering
audacious sums of money to pride golfers
from pga tour with woods offer being the
most lucrative total known to date so
what do you think about you know why
this has become so controversial you
know oh my god i cannot believe you're
gonna go and take money from you know
saudi arabia why would you do that do
you realize what they do over there what
are your thoughts on this this is my
very first time
hearing anything about this and i'm not
i'm not even familiar with live golf is
what what exactly is live golf
oh you're this is you have no clue this
is totally new really i'm totally new so
do you want to kind of tell them what's
going on with live golf yeah not that
i'm a huge golf guy but basically they
started a competitive uh
league two
or championship series to basically the
pga okay so and now they're basically
let's see who's who can be bought well
phil mickelson can be bought this guy's
gotta have a lot of problems boom let's
buy that guy he's a big name boom here's
a couple hundred million good good good
for you
good and then there's there's names
after names big golf guy exactly okay
who can be bought who can be bought away
from the pga the way that i'm processing
this is like
you know what china has done in the nba
why you know lebron takes a lot of heat
and a lot of the nba players but they
don't speak about what's going on in
china and the totalitarian state that's
going on there and the uyghurs that are
forced to do whatever are allegedly that
they have to do
a whole lot of tv money exactly so you
know so basically i think saudi arabia
sort of took the blueprint of what the
uh china has done uh with the nba and
said all right
let's do a little golf league here and
let's see how many players we can
purchase
so live golf it's a saudi company it's a
saudi company okay exactly
and uh
you know players are for hire and uh
tiger woods they said all right he's the
biggest name in golf how much is it
gonna cost to buy tiger and allegedly
that number is going to be more than 800
million because he said no to that
interesting so when they throw a b on
there is tiger going to say yes he's
going to say no we'll see what happens
but
uh and greg norman the shark right
i think he's what the director of
operations what is he the president and
ceo
yeah okay so
interesting and then obviously there was
a lot of backlash last week at trump's
golf course because they hosted i think
a big live event and you had a lot of
um
descendants right advocates basically
saying
all right i mean they they some some
stuff was declassified recently about
saudi arabia and basically their role in
911
and it wasn't pretty for saudi arabia
and then you can throw on top of that
the whole jamal khashoggi thing you know
you know
blood on the hands what you know how
much can does it cost for you to be
bought i think is the big question here
that's right so i mean how are you
you're a golf guy what's going on yeah
what do you think is going on here with
live golf and tiger so there's a couple
things that are going on uh first of all
the pga tour has always been
heavy-handed whenever you have a
monopoly whether it's the nfl the nba or
major league baseball you always have
these conflicts between players and the
players associations they always
unionize versus
versus the um
so you have the owners and the stadiums
on this hand and then we have the
players associations on this hand and
the tv money goes over here and then
they give them contracts to play well
it's that way in golf too and
the
interesting thing about it is the pga
tour has been kind of heavy-handed
and they've been inconsistent on things
dustin johnson was a very very popular
golfer who
flunked three drug tests that we now
know
for using coke and
instead they said he's taking a
six-month leave of absence because he
hurt his back jet skiing
and everybody in the tour was like what
sort of bs is this why can't we just
come out and say he failed the drug test
any drugs or performance-enhancing drugs
we don't want them in our sport
including
you know recreational abuse drugs so
there's always been this this thing with
the pga similar to the way the nba
sometimes or nfl will suspend this
player not that player you know when
things happen
and uh so it opened the door for a
competitive series and they had big
saudi money behind him and says tell you
what there's no monopoly
um
pga tour players get to play in the
british open the open you know you don't
have to be member of the tour you're
invited to the open you're invited to
the u.s open you're invited to the
masters those are not pga tour events
they're all independent the majors
except the pga and so
finally the pop boil's over and they're
like well what if we got a bunch of
money and started a competing global
league
and what if we paid people
to come into the league so we could
prime the pump and get some people you
know here and that's what's happened big
names right and it happens to be it
comes with saudi arabia and the
underlying social things that people
know about
but that's what's happened they've tried
to compete a competitive league and
they've paid some big um appearance fees
by the way appearance fees have been
around in tennis forever right uh the
joker gets three and a half million
dollars to appear at certain tournaments
um that are not mainstream so here's
about tigers let me just read what tiger
said okay so in other words like to to
really compare
uh uh uh
paul just said something very
interesting he says liv golf is like the
jake paul of the golf world okay so
they're kind of cutting the big checks
is what they're doing okay uh and and
here's a comment from tiger woods i'll
just read it
i said uh at 2022 uh uh open
championships he was asked about joining
live
he said i disagree with it
uh i think that they've done uh is
they've turned their back on what has
allowed them to get to this position
i know that the pga tour stands for i
know what the pga tour stands for and
what we have done and what the tour has
given us the ability to chase after our
careers and to earn what we get and the
trophies we have been able to play for
in the history that has been part of
this game um this is his comments when
he turned down
seven or eight hundred million dollars
tom when you hear that
knowing tiger what do you think about
tiger saying something like that well i
think
tigers had his own set of headlines for
which he could have been suspended in
many sports unfortunately um and
tiger is just saying don't bite the hand
that feeds you we don't need change
that's all he's saying that's always
you know you were he's also worth a
billion dollars so it's easy if you're
worth a billion dollars to kind of turn
down however many hundred million and
that is bubba watson's point right and
so if you're if you're only worth a
couple million bucks and you've been
working your ass off your whole life and
you're 48 years old whatever your number
is or you're 35 years old and you're
number 25 in the world you've gotten up
there to that level and they're going to
offer you
a walk across appearance fee of 20
million exactly part of the tour you
look at it and you say wow but at the
end of the day it just comes down can
you be bought
can you be bought i don't think and i
know there's anything wrong with that
it's do you want to wait well is it it's
a professional athlete taking the
biggest
contract on the table being bought
that's what i was about to say
defined being bought it depends well
being bought is suggesting that there's
some
major uh objective ethical issue with it
well i mean if you're american as an
example
like you did hear the news about all the
people
protesting at trump's golf course in new
jersey you heard about this no yes no
okay but okay so all right
over the last week or so
i mean we've all known that saudi arabia
has played some sort of role in 9 11.
you've heard this right well the highest
some many of the people who committed it
i know were saudi nationals correct the
government i'm not aware i haven't
looked into all that but apparently now
the full-on came out and they said no
the government did have a role straight
up this is not my opinion this is what
is going on circulating so
and then you throw on the jamal
khashoggi thing
right
so
that's the question i know you're saudi
so this is like saudi no you you you
didn't then you live in saudi arabia i
live there man i'm not i'm not saudi
okay well yeah you defense out you
defend you like you don't don't put
words in my mouth please but but zooby
you came out and you said that you liked
saudi arabia
more than america or more than new york
city no i didn't say that what are you
talking about bro that was the whole
cliff that went viral in new york city
not america isn't it okay yeah man like
i never said that yeah i said new york
city i apologize but i did say that yes
but you were defending saudi arabia more
like the new york city easily correct
but a lot of americans would disagree
with you bro but they've never been okay
correct but i don't think their people
are clamoring to go to saudi because of
what we've assumed about saudi arabia
okay bringing it back to the gulf
situation is
you know people are very uneasy with uh
saudi arabia especially with their role
in 911 here so that's the story here i
mean nobody's nobody if if the uae
started this nobody would be talking
smack about this right if the country of
jordan did this it's because of the
connotations with saudi arabia yeah but
the saudi arabia had a role in 9 11
period full stop so if you're american
you're probably gonna have an issue with
saudi arabia and i get that there's some
sort of a fringe ally whatever you know
they're uh opposite of iran you know
where who who who does saudi arabia buy
all their weapons from
united states okay exactly that's why i
said there's some sort of fringe ally
this is the [ __ ] debate bro
this is the debate i mean it's like
people are so inconsistent what bothers
me is like the inconsistency on these
things well it's because it's because
saudi arabia is inconsistent on one hand
they'll buy weapons off us and they'll
be our ally but on the other hand
there's a report that comes out and says
that the government did have a role in 9
11. well look greg norman made a really
good point and i i watched his interview
and people said well that's really you
know apples and oranges no it wasn't he
pointed out that one of the top three
sponsors this year in the lpga is aramco
whoops wait a minute
where are they what's audio ramco
correct and he pointed out he said take
the top 10 advertisers or something from
the pga and look at how many of them are
energy or massive banking consulting
companies that have massive not just a
couple million dollars but massive
economic relationships with kingdom of
saudi arabia ksc and the government for
years and years and years not just that
they did a deal this year but they've
been this it said so why is it so bad
that that that you know you've got royal
money and country money coming out to
create this golf league when
sponsors here you know uh you know
are they real high-end moralists are
they turning a blind eye are they just
doing business these people are the
inconsistency is is ridiculous what
about what about china how much business
how much stuff is everything's made in
china everything's bought from like if
someone was to even attempt to be
moderately consistent on this then you
can't
you kind of can't really do anything and
this is one of the sort of saddest
things about the world
is i often think
um this is kind of getting a little
philosophical but i often i'm intrigued
by the concept of uh
what i would call complicity with evil
right uh
because
unfortunately it's impossible for any of
us just by paying taxes just by living
just by buying things
there's a degree of complicity with
things that we all have moral and
ethical issues with right we all have
smartphones right where where is the the
mine the mining of some of the materials
that are used for smartphones called
tenants
like everything you buy right you're
buying something from from you're buying
nike shoes or the foxconn factory you're
buying electronics right like whatever
you're buying
there is somewhere down the line most
likely something you have an ethical
issue with factory farming like
everything even just paying taxes even
the way your own government spends money
right you you you pay your taxes and
then they go and start some foreign war
that you are completely opposed to
whether it was you know iraq in our
lifetime like seoul all these military
interventions
and
it's it's just messy it happens on a
governmental level it happens on an
individual level and so on and i'm a big
fan of doing my best to try to
reduce what i'd consider my complicity
with evil it's actually part of a reason
why i tend to lean more libertarian on
many things because i'm like man i don't
want
it's one thing taxing me and those taxes
are going towards uh schooling or
helping homeless people or helping
widows or so on it's another thing
taxing me and then you go and you spend
that money on some crap that i totally
totally disagree with and have no say in
so i think all of this stuff is is very
is very very messy and it's confusing
because
you've got we know what the ccp is up to
you've already talked about we they're
literally
got concentration camps literally right
um saudi arabia has its sins russia eve
every country has since
western countries have their sins too
but they're all
working
it's so complicated that's the thing
with me so when i see stuff like this
i'm kind of like well
you know each i think each individual
should make their choice i think if
tiger woods is like you know what i have
an ethical issue with this the same
thing happened by the way i know because
they did the um crown jewel wwe events
in saudi arabia over the last couple
years and some of the wrestlers were
like you know what i don't wanna i don't
wanna participate in this event in in
saudi arabia i have some kind of ethical
issue with this i'm gonna step aside for
this one other wrestlers were like you
know what some of them thought
completely differently some were like
you know what actually this is an
opportunity
to
look the country is becoming the idea of
even having a wwe event in saudi arabia
10 years ago was absurd it wouldn't have
happened so their country is actually
liberalizing and opening up in various
ways and they're like okay
this is an opportunity
to use our talents to help
open open things up and then later down
the line
you know it's going to be a process and
by the way i think people often forget
one more thing one more thing my brain
is jumping around everywhere because
it's such an interesting topic to me is
also i think people also forget that
countries
take time to get to places where was the
usa in 1922
right where was the usa even at the
great depression
yeah but i mean from a from a social
from a social standpoint you have the
freaking cake millions of kkk members
running around people getting lit like
100 years like stuff was bad like
countries take time like his history is
dirty history's messy it's violent it's
nasty you've had genocides you've had
wars all of this and countries
change and they progress and things are
not stagnant where things are right now
is not where they'll be in the future so
i do think that
many westerners and western countries
despite all their own sins which i won't
even get into
oftentimes they're like okay well we're
here right now in 2022 i think
super woke people especially have this
problem
and so we want to like snap our fingers
and expect everywhere else around the
world across africa across asia across
the middle east like they should all
just be they should all just be like us
get on our level just like this
but 20 years ago
like you know
take a topic like i don't easy one gay
marriage
right 20 years ago
your opinion and the general opinion on
the same is this the exact same thing
the view is in nigeria right so you're
here now trying to like pressure these
countries and push oh they're so
backwards like it's like bro like 20
years ago
that wasn't even the opinion here let's
be real so
why are you like expecting okay well
this thing changes here we should snap
our fingers and buy magic all the
billions of people in the world just
suddenly shift views that they've held
for centuries it's like
it's a messy one so i've said a lot
there i've got a lot of thoughts on it
but um i just think it's it's it's a
complicated thing i would say it's it's
actually very simple you know okay
they're they have competition
and
you know pga has had a uh
monopoly for a long time and there's
never been a second league to compete
against stan look we're in the insurance
industry let me tell you
i wish you knew how much competition
we've had every freaking day that we got
to figure out a way to improve you know
everybody's like well you know how about
that podcast this podcast that podcast
what if this guy what if that guy look
if you have a message
we started with zero subscribers
and audiences showed up because we had
to get better if you don't get an
audience you're not interesting the
audience will say it you can try to do
whatever you want to do people can say
whatever they want to say about mr beast
or people can't say whatever they want
to say about pewdiepie or rogan
they are interesting and people want to
hear what they have to say and there's
competition
today you know how many podcasts there
is today you know how many podcasts
there's today worldwide millions 400
million podcasts today okay 100 million
there's there it's a massive number
worldwide in the us i think i'm sorry in
the us there's four million podcasts in
the us there's four million podcasts you
got four million podcasts to choose from
okay
400 million no no no in the us the
number i'm giving you something
no u.s 400 is an accurate number in us
there's four million podcasts okay
how many podcasts do you got to choose
from oh my god like imagine how
competitive that is so pga tour is upset
because there's going to be one
other
golf
competition for you i'm sorry pga
you you you know you you have now
somebody that you're competing against
so yeah if they can pull it off you know
great look what uh dana white said they
know what says the best thing when jake
paul says stuff to him you know what he
says good you want to pay him better
start a league no one is stopping her
start a league go for it if you want to
start a league and compete against us
and pay people better start a league see
how you can do it
go see how many have tried so if liv
thinks they can do it better
and they think their method of doing
this is by cutting the big checks that
you got oil and you go get a badass guy
like greg norman
who is going to be making these calls to
them
all right see how it works out it may or
may not work out props to tiger for
saying yeah i'm not taking it
and uh he chose this position that he
chose but you cannot make this about
saudis are linked to 911 because when
the moment you play that card
you're messing yourself up because the
game of hypocrisy is going to come back
and catch up to you man the game of
hypocrisy
is is not a good game to play you can
sit there and try to judge people the
moment you play the judgment game
first thing that happens is if somebody
like you know how they said well you do
you realize what you did when you were
you did this and you did that you did
this all the person has to say i'm sorry
for everybody watching if you ever went
to high school with this guy or college
with this guy can you please email us
whatever you have on this guy are you
okay with that mr mr reporter well no no
no no okay then listen maybe like chill
out we all got stuff in the skeletons in
the closet and we've all made mistakes
kind of relax and let's compete and see
who's going to get better and then if
you got a better argument i'd live more
power to you you don't you don't trump
try to start a league nfl who's the one
player he picked up do you guys remember
steve young who else did he pick up the
the name that now was running for
senator christopher walker herschel
walker
it was the biggest thing when trump
started a football league new jersey
generals and he went and brought
herschel walker and herschel walker said
no to the nfl but he said yes to trump
why because they paid better so is
herschel walker's a guy that's for sale
and then he went there and he's like you
know what trump you failed i'm going to
go to the nba and to the nfl and then so
this is not easy to do there's a lot of
xflowers out there people have tried aba
was out there julius irving used to be
part of aba before nba bunch of guys
played for aba so we're going to find
out if they can compete here's the truth
it's going to take a lot more than money
to be able to compete against the pga a
lot more money yeah than that so we'll
see if they'll pull it off or not
anyways it's definitely interesting yeah
it's more interesting they're not
cutting players all the players are
getting paid they have teams you're
bringing hot young names you're changing
up the format it's not boring old pga
tour they're going to cater to the young
audience and they're going to pull it
off
they will pull this off you know what i
like about this tyler you know what i
like about that i agree
you look like you could be the nephew of
greg norman by the way it's like is
there a relationship where you're
defending them or maybe a little bit of
saudi with your beard that you got no i
used to i used to play a lot of golf man
i'm a big fan of the sport and i think
the pga is boring i think it's very
hypocritical of tiger as a billion
dollar athlete to sit here and criticize
these guys imagine you're pat perez on
tour for 20 years okay you're traveling
around the country you're paying your
caddy you're paying a ship all your
stuff and now you're now now you can go
to a great where you can get paid every
event you're the 48th last place makes
120 grand per event
i love it that's the point go do it see
how you do i'll play it go go do it yeah
right right see if you pull it 120 grand
for coming last time yeah yeah
let's go you have to be in like the top
30 in a pga event to make to make any
money let's talk about
tyler with your permission can we talk
about geico if that's okay with your
life i think it's great let's go talk
about geico let's go talk about geico
okay
so geico
closes all california offices lays off
workers okay
they've reportedly closed all their 38
of its agent offices in california laid
off hundreds of employees and will no
longer sell insurance through telephone
agents in the state california can still
obtain geico policies in the state but
will only go through a computer or
mobile service posing a challenge for
those who are not technology
technologically proficient california
has a strong insurance market more than
130 companies competing for consumers
private passenger auto business and more
than 70 companies writing homeowners
insurance the california apartment
insurance said we encourage consumers to
look at their options for coverage in
california competitive marketplace so
now why did geico leave
geico's name is not a small name they're
everywhere branding their commercial
their gecko they've made some of the
funniest commercials what are you doing
leaving the state of california you're
in the insurance business why do you
think this is happening
i have zero clue a guy goes down to do
this all i know is that a lot of
companies are cutting staff these days
we've seen that robin hood just cut a
bunch of staff facebook mark zuckerberg
has come out and said his staff
there's something going on in uh in
california though that's for sure is
that where you're going with this yeah
listen
the question this is this is what's
unique about this article it didn't say
geico is shutting down 78 offices
nationwide
okay it says they're shutting down all
of their offices in one
specific state why
why why are you only
closing all of your offices it didn't
even say they're closing 38 of their 92
offices in the state of california it's
saying they're closing
all
38 of it office offices in california is
the climate bad in california
are you choosing to leave is the
regulation just not worth it are the
taxes just not worth it is the cost per
lead you're getting that you have to pay
the commission for the agents to make
money for the lease you're paying for
the building to get the customer support
to be there and then have to go through
the loopholes that the state of
california offers just not worth it i
don't know but this story that title
right there says a lot geico has closed
all 38 of its of locations in california
does not say any other state and doesn't
say a percentage of their offices it
says all that makes you think tom what
do you think i think it's a business
environment in california because geico
is not leaving
geico is continuing to service and to
sell to consumers in the seventh largest
economy in the world california so
they're not leaving
they're not leaving they're just saying
it is hard to do business here in
california what and you know what i
think it could be a combination of or
all the reasons pat just said and
they're like you know what we're out of
here but also i take a look through the
between the lines really quickly
hundreds of employees will no longer
sell insurance through telephone agents
in the state could it be that finding
that being able to pay people to be a
telephone agent in california does not
match with the cost of living in
california maybe they can't find enough
of these agents i don't know but what
this says to me hey we're still going to
sell this online but we're not going to
have
you know offices in california i think
it means the california business climate
was
was difficult they still want the
business from the seventh largest
economy with the greatest automobile
culture in america what do they don't
want that market of course they want
that market yeah i think where you're
basically saying this is a metaphor for
why you left california you're in the
insurance business here is this i mean
i'm reading between the tea leaves here
actually there was a reason you left
california a lot of people between the
lines and reading the tea leaves yeah
both of those things between between the
lines and the smoke and some tea leaves
the um
speaking there must be a there must be
exactly there must be a reason no we
didn't do this taxes regulation is
ultimately why you left california but
what i'm trying to say to you is we
didn't leave california so i'm if if i
the the uh you're saying that california
left you no no he's saying we are
permanently shut down and can't
write new policies
in california an agent told the reporter
on thursday so an agent who worked for
geico that's 38 offices i don't know how
many hundreds of agents but an agent
said i can't no longer sell geico in the
state of california that's like php
saying hey to all the people that are in
california you can no longer sell in
california why would a company this size
shut down a state that's the sixth or
seventh largest economy in the world
why would you do it that's what i'm
interested in knowing because there
there is a uh
you know like the uh
she no came out shakira's getting a
divorce her and her husband getting a
divorce remember that and then a month
later the story comes out and says what
taxes they got eight years going to jail
for uh taxes okay so you're like oh
what happened there okay
you know because if you're married you
got tax issues who's linked to the tax
issues if you're married both of you if
you're divorced is it you so you don't
know maybe we're not going to know why
geico left california
all i'm saying is
why is a company as big and pro you know
who owns geico you know who's the
biggest shareholder in geico it's
buffett
so you think buffett
you know like i don't know i i just
think there's got to be something going
on there with the climate that's getting
somebody like this to say
we're leaving the sixth largest economy
and we've got to get you to think about
that pat that's a great point and who
runs to the microphone the california
state
department of insurance
and uh
it says
hang on everything's okay we encourage
consumers look at their options for
coverage in california's competitive
marketplace that's kind of the way that
quote that's that
that's a freaked out bureaucrat saying
everything's cool california we got all
these insurance companies no problem
you've got a lot of choices you know
they're out there running out there
saying everything's cool why is the
state running out to say all is well
when a company moves the answer is
i think it was the regulatory
environment that's my guess what's so
interesting about all these
conversations is they're they're all
really about competition
right it's it's it's competition because
this is the same this is what's
happening playing out right now in the
usa especially over the past three years
is just competition right people
migrating and moving to where makes
sense california is losing people
florida is gaining people and so on and
so forth and so
to me it's interesting you know i i feel
i feel bad for
the people who end up kind of
just casualty like this
how many people just lost their jobs
from this right like that
that sucks
um but i do think in the long term with
all of this stuff it's gonna be really
interesting to see
where it all goes i think we're at such
a transition point
right now in our countries in so many
ways
and it's scary and it's unnerving and
it's freaking a lot of people out
in many ways for many different reasons
but i think that in the long term it's
going to be
it's going to be interesting just to see
where it lands and see where see where
stuff is in 10 years from now it would
be really interesting it's going to be
we'll see what's going on but all i know
is you know this is a little bit uh
strange when somebody as big as geico as
profitable as geico
leaves the biggest economy in america
what are you doing leaving that place
yeah it's a very strange move to
leave you got so many potential
customers that can no longer be written
by agents this is a very very weird move
and it's terrible for the department of
insurance by the way let's change
transition let's go into a different
topic zelinski
okay so report came out deep mistrust
has developed between white house and
zelinski this is a hot air story
an ominous detail is very buried in tom
friedman's column this is a guy who had
lunch at the white house with biden less
than three months ago
the timing of pelosi's visit could not
be worse dear reader the ukraine war is
not over and privately u.s officials
are a lot more concerned about ukraine's
leadership than they are letting on
there is deep mistrust between the white
house and president zelinski of ukraine
considerably more
than has been reported on and there's a
funny business there's funny business
going on in kiev on july 17 zelichke
fired his country's prosecutor general
and the leader of its domestic
intelligence agency the most significant
shake-up in his government since the
russian invasion in february it would be
the equivalent of biden firing merrick
garland
and bill burns on the same day
but i have still not seen any reporting
that convincingly explains what was that
all about it is as if we don't want to
look too closely under the hood in kiev
for fear of what corruption or antics
might we might see
when we have invested so much there
that's a very well written article by
the way to make makes you makes you
think about what's really going on over
there tyler i'll go to you first what do
you think's going on with this
i think that
the white house is exactly what it says
they're terrified to see that ukraine is
exceptionally corrupt but it's never
been a true democracy that it's always
been an oligarchy and it's always been
exceptionally corrupt it was what the
the third most corrupt country in the
world
like they ranked these things and it's
it's always been hugely corrupt we've
now sent them what 51 billion dollars 52
billion dollars and they know they
[ __ ] up they don't want to look
they're afraid of it but then ben
stiller says zielinski's his hero he
flew out there and said yeah you two did
the concert in the subway
this thing's been so weird zolensky's
had russian uh assassins after him since
the war started but he can do his his
shoot with vogue you've got people going
to the beach it's i mean it's it's weird
man it's one reason why i i've been very
silent since this whole thing kicked off
because from day one
it's just struck me as weird
i i don't get what's going on and
again this comes back to a point i was
making earlier which is
with this situation and so many others i
think oftentimes people conflate
governments with the people
right so when someone even says
i stand with ukraine or i support
ukraine
what does that mean or if someone has
you know says they don't like the usa or
they don't like saudi arabia or whatever
it is and
i think it's always a mistake to
conflate
governments with the people
of a country i think anyone who's
traveled knows these things are very
very different and that the ccp is not
representative of
chinese people in general the us
government absolutely
is not in uh
you know
i i think virtually every america i feel
like every american i've met
is like a is better than the top people
in the government and so on like so the
notion that the government and the
people are the same thing is very messy
so i think with this situation it's been
confusing because of course you have all
the all the nonsense on social media but
when someone criticizes or is critical
of zilensky or the ukrainian government
or says they're corrupt right people
automatically jump oh so you're pure
proprietor and you're pro russia you
don't care about the ukrainian people
it's like no you can totally care about
the people who have been killed injured
displaced from their homes etc you can
have complete compassion for those
people
but you can also recognize okay at a
governmental level here
there's something weird going on here
you've got that whole azov battalion in
there and you've got actual neo-nazis
who are fighting in the war
i don't know all the details but it's
messy and i think people try to really
simplify it and just be like okay either
you're pro russia or your pro your pro
ukraine and it's just like well
what does that even
what does that even mean i think we're
so quick to
label all right that putin's the bad guy
so those guys must be the good guys it's
you know it's there's a lot of gray
areas where you're talking about there's
more than meets the eye
everyone wants to label russia the bad
guy and then ukraine are the good guys
so zielinski is the face of ukraine you
know good-looking young guy what have
you so he's the good guy but i think
what we're learning is maybe there it's
sort of a lesser of two evils thing
russia can be the bad guy putin could be
the bad guy but at the same time
ukraine zielinski can still be corrupt
like tyler was talking about you so this
could be about war yeah i mean it's it's
just not it's not a black and white
thing bad [ __ ]
exactly and and i don't speak on it too
much as well because i'm aware that this
stuff has been going on for for decades
these countries have decades
of of history and i'm very far you know
there's people who didn't know what
ukraine meant was
right well pat you remember when we we
had oliver stone here yeah okay you
remember the conversations there with
what he was talking about very different
perspective yes and like and it's not
this perspective you're gonna hear from
mainstream media people were upset about
what he was saying so
look i mean when the when when this
thing but but the whole thing with
timing is what the the writer is making
you think because while this is going on
and what ukraine is to russia is what
taiwan is to
china the closest correlation and you go
during this time
i don't know it's kind of uh you know
it's kind of interesting what's going on
over here
one thing i've been thinking about a lot
over the last few months and people have
brought this point up i'm not the only
one but
i think on a world level
the usa certainly from a governmental
perspective is looking weak and
incompetent right now
and i think that was massively
exemplified by the people have already
forgotten about the uh afghanistan
pull-out last year i mean oh my gosh
that was a complete catastrophe and i
think that with this
you know i don't even want i don't want
to be that guy who's i do wonder i do
wonder
would all of this have happened under
trump would you russia have invaded
ukraine
trying to be making the moves is making
i doubt it it's conjecture i don't know
but i think that the usa i think with
biden is looking we i mean you've got
dudes in in dresses
like in the in the cabinet you've got
diversity highs they're militaries
putting out woke ads and whatever i
think if i were in china or i were
russia and i was like some general or so
i'd be looking over the u.s and being
like okay
okay right don't interrupt your enemy
when they're when they're making a
mistake right like
it's just looking soft and weak the usa
is not looking as strong on national
stage as strong and as competent as it
did previously whether it's under trump
or under obama or under bush or so on
and i think that china and russia are
seeing that and
i would assume that's why some of these
moves
are being made at this point because the
administration is just
just looking weak i mean the president
can't string sentences together
greatest motivational speaker of all
time so it's you gotta you gotta give
credit what credits do okay we got a
couple minutes left what story do we
wanna go into right now with what we got
going on
uh
since we're talking about california
what is going on with all the uh the
drug stuff oh do you want to talk about
the drug stuff okay california to fund
heroin injection sites in la oakland and
san francisco okay what uh what a
brilliant strategy so let's cover this
one here to see what they're doing there
uh a bill passed monday in the
california state legislature
would enable la oakland and san
francisco to open heroin injection sites
for drug users the bill would authorize
cities and counties to establish safe
consumption sites where addicts could
use illegal narcotics under supervision
those success in the hygienic
space supervised by trained staff guys
they're trained
could consume pre-obtained drugs program
staff would be trained to administer an
opioid antagonist
in the event of an overdose
under federal law it is currently a
felony to operate a space to distribute
or use a controlled substance president
biden co-authored the federal state
statute
during his time as a senator
how do you even respond to this uh react
to this article here so you can
illegally buy heroin on the corner and
then walk into a safe space where
they're gonna give you a clean needle
and a
iodine or an alcohol kit for your point
of injection
okay and by the way the um opioid
antagonist
in modern parlance that's like an epipen
like when people have uh like when
people have allergies you have to carry
that like a child with peanut butter or
bee sting it's it's a it's a big adult
version of that oh you're having a
oh the guy's having an overdose hit him
with a narcan right yeah exactly similar
exactly right um hit him with that so
it just is shocking to me it's it's this
is really shocking why
why would we help to perpetuate
someone's
situation with such a drug like heroin
and bad brown is is
is is the hardest to kick you know as
they refer to
what they call their harm so-called harm
reduction policies isn't it have you
guys read us but where's the methadone
helping these people maybe to get off it
back to some other place no no i'm have
you have you guys read a san francisco
schellenberger have you read that book
i've not read it but i've i've seen a
lot of stuff here yeah i i'd really
recommend reading that book because i
went to california for the first time in
my life in 2019 um and
i was
i was shocked by l.a and san francisco i
saw stuff in those two cities i'd never
seen anywhere else in any city in my
entire life and this is 2019 and stuff
in many ways has worsened since then but
those places are they're not normal my
mind was blown i was so confused i was
in san francisco for a week and i was
like interview i was like informally
interviewing uber drivers and everyone
just like what is going on in the city
why is it why is it like this i mean i
remember being out there and i was in a
park it was 8 p.m on a saturday and
there were like 20 people just shooting
heroin in the park behind me just just
casually i was i've never seen that
before just out there and the open
people are walking past going out to
clubs going to restaurants and whatever
there's people doing heroin i was like
this is not
normal and then i was so intrigued by it
and i got led to this book and i was
reading about it and the history and why
the policies are like this and so on so
this does not surprise me in the
slightest
um
but it's insane these places i've
described california as a beautiful
place
run by complete idiots i think it's run
by complete crazy people with no grasp
on reality
and um it's sad it's sad because san
francisco is a beautiful city
architecturally weather in la is
fantastic like these are these are cool
places but
the policies are just
nuts on so many levels and they just
keep getting worse it's almost like
they're trying to drive people out
in san francisco in product 2018 2019 i
was with my girlfriend at the time
and we checked into our hotel cool we
got we were so excited we drove from l.a
did the
what is it the 101 highway up in
california yeah did the drive uh big sur
if you ever drift through big sur it is
ridiculous talk about gorgeous
forget about it and then we get the
scent we're so excited it's the new york
city of the west you know it's like and
we get checked in the hotel and we asked
the um
the bellhop or the uh the person at the
front desk which way to go they go
definitely don't walk that way yeah like
because it's night time don't go that
way go this way even that way
long story short my girlfriend she's
like dude we get like what the [ __ ] is
this city get me out of here yep i go we
we're here for four days let's give it
some time we'll stay up tomorrow and we
went to like fisherman's wharf and we
and it was actually really nice
uh but there are parts of it that are
absolutely
insane fourth world disgusting like what
the hell is happening here
and that's the most expensive city to
live in america new york and san
francisco so it's like there's this
ridiculous profound wealth because of
the big tech and everything that's gone
in silicon valley and then there's just
this disgustingness that's happening
on the underbelly and not even so much
the underbelly because it's out there
it's in the center it's in the center
but
it's it's just like this backwards thing
and and on the surface even this story
is disgusting all right so i can come in
and do heroin professionally what a
mature way to do heroin
and i've lost some friends to overdose
whether it's opioids whether it's you
know this kind of crazy stuff
and i'm trying to wrap my head around
why they would implement policies like
this yeah and the only thing that i can
really come up with is the fact that
well these people are going to do it
anyway yeah so if they're trying to
prevent
deaths
and overdoses and sharing disgusting
needles and if people are going to do it
anyway
why not allow them to do it in a safe
space now i'm not a i'm not an advocate
of heroin or pills or overdosing but
there must be some methodology to the
madness yeah i think it's kind of um
and a lot people on the kind of far left
progressives
can have this type of
almost like toxic compassion it's the
opposite of tough love
they're completely opposed to tough love
right
it's this
but but it's to the you ever seen those
programs where someone weighs like 600
pounds or 700 and you know their mom is
still feeding them why are you feeding
because i because i love him i care for
him right like they're so unwilling to
enact anything that is just like look
you can't do this so it's so permissive
that it ends up being destructive yes
right and actually and i fully agree
with you yeah it's the same they've done
that you know with the shoplifting right
you know you can shoplift up to 900 or
cause criminal damage up to 900
um and it's not a felony right or the
the way that they have the tents and
they're people just injecting or
whatever as long as you're not you know
physically assaulting someone but here's
here's what i'm going to ask you guys i
want to ask you guys this question
so tell me this policy
of
creating a safe space
for heroin addicts to go use heroin
i want to hear from
who the hell says what an honorable
thing to do like
give me be the devil's advocate and
don't think logically okay okay
and and go to the person that says that
maybe they lost somebody to heroin
or like who's gonna say
man what a great idea
sell me that can you even do that like
do you understand what i'm asking i i
think i do okay so
i think i know how they come from i
think there's there's two perspectives
there's the number one
this is where i i'm not
this is this is one thing where i i'm
not sure i i don't think my
the libertarian
thought process really works on this one
but number one is the whole
your body your choice you're not hurting
it you're not hurt as long as you're not
hurting anybody else you should have the
right and it should be legal for you to
consume whatever you want put whatever
you want into your body so there's that
there's that libertarian
approach of just like well that's up to
you has should have nothing to do with
the government so on and then there's
the more um progressive side which i
believe they call these productions uh
sorry they call these policies harm
reduction which is as you alluded to
people are gonna do this anyway
so it is safer for them to
be using clean needles and to have some
staff in case they overdose and people
who know how to use narcan and so on
that is they're going to do it anyway so
it's better for them
to do it in this type of environment i
think it using the principle of charity
that's those two things combined or how
they think this is not a crime this is
not a crime this is an addiction it's an
illness
and we need to be kind and compassionate
and take care of people and fine so
that's how they view it so okay
so both is it fair to say that both
democrats and republicans have lost
people to drugs yes okay
so whether you're a democrat or
republican who lost somebody to drugs
if somebody came and said hey i'm going
to help your kid
would you want me to help your kid
regardless of where you lean politically
i'm going to help your kid by bringing
them to my house it's going to be safe
i'll help them take to her home but it's
gonna be in my house in a safe place and
i'll feed them
is that what you want me to do with your
kid left right middle doesn't matter
what you are politically
do so do you understand what i'm saying
so you got a kid okay adam don't worry
about it man he's gonna be able to do
the heroin at my house it's going to be
a safe place you got nothing to worry
about how would you like me if you've
lost because a lot of these parents
every one of these people has a parent
that's going on through this heroin and
they have made a bad mistake bad
association
someone's in a lot of pain watching
their kids being addicted to drugs yes
i've seen parents it's
you can't we can't do nothing like you
they can't go to work
you're in the middle of the day you're
working all you're thinking about is my
kid is a freaking addict okay so
the only thing they're hoping i just
want my baby back i want my kid back
kids whose parents became addicts
siblings whose sibling became an addict
friends whose friend became an addict
what do they want their friend to do
i'll give you the policy that's coming
to mind today that i think that we can
all relate to because i don't know a lot
of people that do heroin and are
addicted to opioids but i do know a lot
of people that like to drink and i
remember in high school there was a
friend who's like we were gonna go drink
beers you know we were 18 17 years old
so one of the dads one of the families
was like look i know what you guys are
gonna go do on the weekends you're gonna
go drink you're gonna have fun you're
gonna get into cars and you're gonna go
drive drunk listen if you're gonna drink
beers i'd rather you hang out in our
backyard do it safely i'll make sure
that everybody gets home safe so i'll be
the adult in the room
and i'll make sure that you guys are
drinking and getting home in a safe
space and there's a part of that that i
think is exactly analogous to this it's
like
teenagers are gonna go have beers anyway
drug addicts are gonna go do heroin
anyway let's try to implement a
safeguard system so people don't [ __ ]
die well so we've we've only done this
halfway because to your point the
libertarian case not only would we have
the safe injection sites we would be
creating the drugs it would no longer be
dirty heroin it would be clean true
honest heroin portugal portugal did this
they decriminalized heroin okay in the
90s one in 100 people was addicted to
heroin they since decriminalized over
the last nearly two decades the number
of heroin users in portugal has been cut
by two-thirds and drug related deaths
had plummeted from more than one a day
in 1999 to 30 in all of 2016. it's like
one of those things where crazy problems
might need crazy solutions stuff that
you think on the surface is like what
you're doing what
that might be something that could work
but it's because they decriminalized
everything yeah
true pure heroine which is very
different than black tar or cocaine cut
with fentanyl or any of this nonsense
when it's actually the true drug it's
very different and in portugal you don't
you don't see all the madness you see in
la and san francisco do you know you
know what i honestly think when it comes
to drug policy
um
this might be controversial to some i
think the only things that
work in practice
are
one or other of the extreme approaches
right no drugs whatsoever it's illegal
you'll go to jail if you do it yes or
you'll be killed or do what you want
the extreme zero tolerance yeah
you know death to drug traffickers or
life imprisonment saudi arabia i think
yeah
saudi arabia i think countries like uh i
think singapore is extreme singapore is
extremely straight there's some cut just
zero tolerance yes right
turkey in the 1970s
in practice that works right in terms of
or you do what oregon did and
decriminalize all drugs here in the
united states yes or the type of
portugal you know just okay we're we're
completely not treating this as a
criminal
issue
um but we're not you know it's not it's
not criminal it's not legal in that you
can just like walk into the grocery
store and and buy cocaine or heroin
but we we do criminalize everything
you have policies and strategies and
things in place to
reduce the risk that someone's even
going to fall into that and so on but
the whole type of like halfway war on
drugs you know where drugs are coming in
and people are doing it but then you're
you're you're trying to you know locking
people up for weed and you're doing it
this kind of half way approach
just is clearly not working interesting
perspective yeah interesting perspective
tell us about your books yeah sure um
okay switching branch uh
so i just released a children's book
it's called the candy calamity it's a
collaboration with a company in texas
called brave books who put out a new
book every single month um and it's all
about health and fitness and taking care
of your body in 2019 i wrote my previous
book strong advice zooby's guide to
fitness for everybody that one's for the
grown-ups that one's for the kids it's a
fun story the whole thing rhymes as a
rapper i had to make sure my first
children's book sick was going to rhyme
so the whole thing it's a fun story um
it's beautifully illustrated and
it's really i'd say for kids maybe
between the ages of four and ten would
probably probably get the most out of it
um i think when you look at kids books
there's there aren't actually that many
about
health and fitness nutrition exercise
why why why is that important why is it
important to take care of your body so
i'm all about putting
positive messages out there trying to
inspire and motivate people of different
ages so i love that's my book it's
available at candycalamity.com
strong advice is available at
teamzubi.com so uh yeah go check that
out gang if you enjoyed zubia as much as
we did today and it looks like you guys
loved having him on today
uh go support him by purchasing both of
his books the links are there in the
chat room as well as in the chat box as
well as uh
in the description go get the book
support zooby zubi once again it's
always great having you on man i
appreciate it guys thank you safe
travels take care everybody bye bye bye
bye
you